[موسيقى]
يشتغل غضب الفلسطينيين بالقدس المحتله
هكذا بدات مداخل حي جبل المكبر في ساعات
الصباح الاولى
وكانها ساحه معركه حيث عمل الاضراب الشامل
مناحي الحياه كافه
يحتاجوا الاهلي هنا على هدم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لمنزل عائله مطر
ويقولون انهم سيتصدون لاي عمليات هدم اخرى
في مقبل
يعني اذا بدنا نرخص ولا بدنا نعمل اي شيء
ما بطلعوا لنا الواحد اللي بده يستنى 20
سنه
لم يخلو الامر من مواجهات بين الفلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال فقد سد الشبان مداخل الحي
بكل ما طالت ايديهم ورشقوا دوريات
الاحتلال بالحجاره ورد الجنود عليهم
بقنابل الغاز المدمع والرصاص المطاطي بحسب
مصادر الطبيه وقعت المواجهات نحو 20
اصابتا في صفوف سكان
الحيض التي تقوده الاحتلال المتطرفات
والافرات بالقتل واعطاء الضوء الاخضر
الجيش الاحتلال وشرطته بقتل اي فلسطين
يتحرك هذا يعزز المطلب الفلسطيني بضروره
ان يكون هناك حمايه دوليه
وما زالت عائله مطر تلملموا جراحها بعد
هدم الاحتلال منزلها فقط كان ذلك ترجمه
سريعه لقرارات المجلس الوزاري المصغر في
اسرائيل الذي اطلق يد الات الهدم للنيل من
المقدسيين بعد عمليتين مسلحتين هزت اركان
حكومه اليمن
[موسيقى]
وحدات النخبه لاسناد قوه الشرطه ودعم
نشاطها في حفظ الوضع الامني
يسدد الاحتلال من قبضه على القدس ويحاصر
احيائها الفلسطينيه بتدابير امنيه لا يبدو
انها ستنتهي قريبا وهو ما يمكن بابا
مواربا على مزيد من الاحتجاجات والمواجهات
التي بدات تتخذ شكلا او ساعه واعم
الجزيره من حي جبل المكبر القدس المحتله